so doing book seven today today
listen that one is concerned with these
different states of the character the
universal put out before and you notice
on cabinets were to Canada schema where
self control myself before they close to
each other and Richard vice further away
from each other and some people virtue
and brutality or sickness are even
further each other that's because this
is supposed to represent how these
states actually are innovations which
are superhuman virtue superhuman her
issue within a religious house would be
something like saintliness Aristotle
actually talks about people being almost
divine so you know the heroes for three
ancient Greeks exhibit exhibited a kind
of superhuman virtue something going
beyond the normal realm over to that the
good people you can point to yet the
prime exemplars
what it means to be a courageous person
generous person or any other virtue that
you want to think of we're not actually
implying much about superhuman for sure
today
aerosol scrutiny so I think we're going
to focus on is mostly this stuff so I
want to hit on each one of these very
quickly brutality or sickness Aristotle
talks about cases in which a person is
not really morally responsible for not
just their actions but the kind of
person that they are the kind of state
that they're in so we could think of
cases like you know really hard for
addictions where we do we actually hold
somebody who's say addicted to crack
cocaine or crystal meth or heroin do we
hold them responsible to the same thing
as we do other people who are addicted
to things some of us do but maybe they
may be pretty Arizona maybe that's a
mistake maybe there's a certain set of
rational for the FPS you're really not
responsible for your actions and one of
the things that aerosol stuff about this
really interesting he says in a certain
way it's less bad than advice but in a
certain sense it's also more prolific
because something
has been lost that was distinctively
human and the reason why I use this as
per mentality is because the Greek word
that their hair cells music actually
means it's something like dannimal
likeness being reduced to your animal
nature the abbot is still functioning as
a human being in certain respects but
not functioning as a human being in
higher respects and the things that make
us human they're within the grips of
something else and you know all the
things may be may be working right there
their intellect may be working in
certain specified figure out what can I
do to get this fix why certain key
things have been shut off revert now and
maybe permanently some drivers can
actually literally destroy parts of your
brain you know hardcore alcoholics who
are close to the enemy they almost can't
do anything seen them you don't rely on
them to be the sort of moral agents that
you do a normal human being even
ambitious somebody who has a bad
character trait that's been established
within them through their own choices
where they actually get things wrong
there sometimes some other cases that
would be like this thinking about when
people have been subjected interviewing
abuse are they responsible for the
reactions in the same way or are they
responsible for their character in the
same way that the rest of us are
Aristotle at the end and say no he
actually brings up the example of sexual
believes practice that exists in some of
our areas okay people in a case like
yeah they've been subjected to horrific
abuse very often they've not been able
to develop in yeah so like the vicious
person they may actually see what
they're doing is good but the vicious
person could be different somebody who's
over here other things you could think
of you know what if there's brain damage
or what if some disease actually screws
up parts of the brain or what if there's
what we call a chemical imbalance in the
brain you know I think of some of the
things that we prescribe medication for
that people respond
I think concern at all yeah what's the
concern okay yeah a lot of people maybe
it is highly that overdiagnosed but the
fact that it's over diagnosed doesn't
mean that it's all just because that
means that people are sloppy through the
diagnosis I mean some people actually do
have some people actually do respond to
housewives obtain its way through crafts
projects there's students who don't have
a TD who take it so they can study cram
for exams there's all sorts of abuse up
there so ritalin seems to be
particularly effective but think of
other things too there's also two B and
D depressants out there why are people
giving those because they're depressed
because they actually feel down
sometimes they're unable to function
there are some doesn't actually talk
about sadness in terms of Richard
buddies interesting but you could you
know some people get more sad than they
ought to without having good reason to
some of those people may not actually
have a cat illogical state some of those
people just
what we call malingerers right or that
may be down all the time because they
choose to be down all the time because
they get something out that would be a
bus but if there's really something
wrong with the person organically
psychologically then the Arizona would
say they're not actually responsible and
they may be some damage that they can't
address we're going at the start this
that's in here so virtue advice nor he
talked a lot about two things it's all
come from a lack of self-control
and the other thing that I want to know
is how do we how we change is gonna be
you notice that i drew this in turn
arrow so that's what let's start with
that we have this arrow here and what
does that representing a path of moral
transformation there's a good moral
promise remember at the beginning of the
semester with super demon virtue we're
just going to leave that picture for
right now because their soul isn't all
that much about
a really great thing with brutality or
sickness it's much harder to change that
sort of thing but these are the things
that are within our power so you know
think for example how do people actually
get better let's say we take somebody
who's got a vicious disposition some of
you may have been in this this case
let's say you had a vicious disposition
with respect to anger or with respect to
your spending habits with respect to
whether you stood up for yourself and
what's right in relation to friends
little calls
obsequious or flattery there's an
ability to actually say no to people
or maybe you were kind of a jerk the
other who's got this virtue of
friendliness yeah you know being
unwilling to get people paying by saying
no to them that's a vice being at the
other end of saying no to everybody and
all you wanted to just do your own thing
or not that would also be advice so
let's say you have a vicious character
with respect to one of these sort of
things now the person who is vicious one
of the things that keeps them in there
is not just the force of Kevin but we've
talked about this many times over the
semester they actually come to think
that that's the right thing to do
so what Aristotle calls their their
moral principle has gotten screwed it's
become corrupted
the image that's the best part of
themselves so the vicious person is
actually at least in one way screwed up
part of themselves could be partly their
fault couldn't produce somebody else's
like you know if your mom and dad were
vicious much greater risk for being
vicious yourself because they're your
models right maybe they have you do
vicious things like the data makes us a
son or daughter fight with other people
all the time stand up for yourself maybe
that kid is going to get anger problems
with full heart when it comes to courage
but at a certain point usually we're too
dull if you have advice you can at least
they're still a door open to saying
somebody ain't coming and saying hey
you're acting like a jerk I don't like
this it should behave like this and then
we're gonna say well this is the way I
should behave this is the right thing
and then somebody else in front they say
you know what it's not the right thing
everybody does yeah look at that guy
over there he doesn't behave like that
and then it could get actually get home
and you could say oh wow I am screwed up
there is something that can you just
stab your fingers I'm gonna put being
like this I think what if you actually
come to the point where you no longer
say yeah it's just fine for me to be as
angry as I want whatever I walk with
and do whatever I want in revenge
retaliation to revenge to them after you
get past them which is going to again
having that moral critical screwed up as
a mix of ice and you start saying wow
I'm really hurting people and alienating
people I don't really like how this
feels and it's making me a worse person
and I usually have some control over
this but now I feel like I had no
control over this empty of that moment
of clarity this was the beginning of
bringing this to me because what happens
the next time you get into a situation
where someone makes you angry can you
say I remember having this moment and I
realized this was a bad thing for me to
do that work does do you have a license
because it was gonna be ethical and you
have certain panama's and it's really
easy to fall back into those those
tendencies so when somebody criticizes
you and you start feeling angry exactly
immediately go away they say Oh I
resolved not to be angry be angry person
it doesn't work that way you have to
actually practice you have to undo the
old habit and eventually kind of
replaces another gap that's this
progress because what happens first do
you know the virtuous person actually
feels good and doing the right things if
you're standing up against your anger
you're going against what you would like
to do you would like to swear it or talk
about
or making a passive-aggressive excuse
bless you or pop them to the nose and
you're doing that you like doing that
sort of thing are you gonna are you
gonna like not doing them you're gonna
find that painful aren't you your
desires are being frustrated you're
actually gonna have to proceeded through
this custard between lack of
self-control
that's all control yeah
what's gonna happen at first is you're
actually going to have to first of all
recognize this is this is not the way I
want to be not just this is not
productive for me when this is turning
people off but you actually have to a
moment of world recognition we say this
is not good I want to be better than
this and then you're over here perhaps
starting to move away from this you know
these runners are not you know sort of
like train stops where you're either at
this station or this nation in this
station or this station these kind of
fade into each other hair cells not
saying that there's using lines to draw
between us you get over here and now you
have bad desires and you recognize them
as bad desires
the question is decision you give into
those bad desires or you fight against
inspires it's going to make yourself do
the right thing now that you can
actually lose have something
because you're now totally polluted the
wrong thing you make yourself do the
right thing even though you want to do
the wrong thing your desired it for you
whether you do more often than not than
you have self control if you don't if
you actually recognize what the right
thing is but you allow your desires to
just pull you whatever way you're going
you're better off than the person who
thinks that they're doing the right
thing by acting like yours but you're
still not as good as the person who's
resisting their insiders who is choosing
to do the right thing because who's
actually gonna make progress present
itself control yeah it's not enough just
in like intentions we all have all sorts
of intentions my intentions were reality
I have like ten languages by them and I
manage to learn why at the end of the
French study well
French and German Latin droopy eye all
sorts of attendants I tend to learn
Italian and actually got some teachers
on Italian books and did a few lessons
in that normal Italian simply desiring
it doesn't make it so I have free
weights at home haven't been picked up
more than like you know once every so
often for a couple of years you're
actually only going to work the place
but does that set put me back in shape
no but you actually have to do things
and it's the same way when it comes to
- moral actions you actually if you want
to be courageous you may actually have
to exercise courage you actually have to
do the sort of things that a crazy
person would do if you want to be
temperate you actually have to do the
sort of things that a temperate person
will do in the situations that call if
you want to get control over your anger
you would actually have to stop your
anger at some point and refrain from
retaliating and try to forgive people as
tough as it is when you don't want to to
do that is to be soft control yeah
injustice is happening and he just I
mean is that pole and they're like being
angry self-control I mean it's
interesting because because Aristotle
would he actually give to this different
classification for that emotion cause
that righteous indignation when you see
somebody who gets away with something
that they want not get away
I suppose in so far as affect you it's
anger and then insofar as its effect
you know trying to do that it's
righteous indignation and the question
would be what you do with the emotional
response because remember with anger
it's not just whether you feel anger
it's whether you feel it at the right
time for the right reason to the
rightest a tiny be active
imagine that you actually like what
after the kind of function well that
would be a problem that would that would
clearly be excessive saying something
doesn't
the difference between the self-control
person of the virtuous person is the
self content person still has some
desires that they can recognize as bad
in the sense of all things are being
excessive the virtuous person actually
has good desires that's part when you
have it will do for you if you if you do
the right thing by forcing yourself to
do the right thing in this situations
that call for this takes a certain sort
of discipline then eventually that will
they'll stick that will become part of
your character will permeate who you are
and it will change over time so you know
think for example of courage with
respect to public speaking right some of
you are still I think a little bit of
afraid of in situations of public
speaking and you don't want to do that
but some of you overcome that fear by
doing it right
some of you didn't worry about it to
begin with but that's pretty rare that
becomes a part of who you are your
desires can be changed they're not just
something that are imposed by the
objects out there there's something you
have some degree of control if you find
that you have an excessive desire for
watching television too much right this
is a trivial example but it would be a
matter of temperance let's say because
we like watching TV right let's say you
find yourself watching six hours of TV
every single day and you find yourself
when you go do other things they can go
to the amusement park with friends or
something like that
I kind of miss being home sitting from
TV watching right you may have a vicious
disposition I mean if you have to tell
yourself this is normal behavior this is
good I should be watching TV as much as
I can but then you've got advice if you
actually you know feel guilty about it
with that you say I watch too much TV
this isn't good for me but you still
keep do it again then you're you're
laughing saw control if you actually ran
it in and you come back to keep you
watching to say in two hours you know
six hours
so you're Raina dead you say I'm gonna
watch two hours a day and then you know
it gets to that that to a point you
could actually watch people would
actually watch it oh yeah
I think my job well you know there's so
many happen so females that by the time
you build your mother you can actually
forget the holiday episode II happen so
you see it again like once you got his
pants up
but so you what was that discipline
yourself you feel kind of a net not
getting to see the show that you want to
see it takes discipline in part because
you don't feel like doing it right but
if we keep doing it eventually you will
acquire that virtue of temperance and
you will want to do things that way you
know you know things will actually make
more sense to think about this in terms
of other virtues and vices if you eat
too much all the time you're not
supposed to and you tell yourself that's
the right thing to do and he actually
feel like that's the right thing to do
you probably got a vicious in this
position then you can also be lack of
self-control you know that you shouldn't
have that third helping and seconds
might be okay in some case it's a
problem let's say it's a third thing now
it's pretty clear right shouldn't have
that third helping but you still do well
then you don't have self-control
let's say you actually exercise
self-control you don't like it right
what's it like to actually go on a diet
you know it makes you irritable with
other people
why does it do that because if your
desires are being checked and the only
thing that's keeping I think about you
know it'd be different if like there
wasn't a food out there right easier to
be restraining food if there was only a
little bit but when you walk across the
street
20 different [ __ ] where the cafeteria
is there anybody following you around
side right now you have enough I think
you should have I think you should leave
you can eat all you want
can't you go out with self control is
your self controlled you'll actually not
like what you're doing at first but
you'll do it could you recognize it's
the right thing to do choose the right
thing and then after a while the smaller
portion actually becomes the right
amount food becomes what you want and it
may be hard it's very hard quite often
with a lot of these things when you're
at this point ever imagine a point where
you're going to a lot but eventually it
does come this is one of the interesting
things about virtue matters until you
actually develop some of the virtues
virtue ethics doesn't make as much sense
it's an ambitious person doesn't make
any sense all the chemicals those
virtuous people they're crazy but it's
really the business person isn't that
sounds crazy now if you can make more
progress you also define okay let's see
the other virtue could you lose that
virtue
how'd you lose your how would you lose a
virtue
okay sure but like we talked when we
were doing play-doh and regards to like
having rationale and then the passionate
side of a person given in to your
desires just because you're virtuous I
don't think the desire necessarily goes
away so if you if ration stops working
rationale against that desire then yet
you start going towards the vice that's
really important somebody somebody comes
along and you've got virtue established
in your character but you're surrounded
with other people
vicious and they're constantly throwing
temptations in your face and they're
telling you things like you know you're
really depriving yourself
and then he starts saying well they call
given on this one and then you do that
one time and Danny Evans did not
virtuous and disappear it away pretty
good and then you say okay I'll do it
the next time the next time and after a
while oftentimes unconsciously without
some proceeding it starts with a slide
and now suddenly you find yourself no
longer being attracted to the judge find
yourself having desires that that you
recognize yeah you're still some
self-control and you're able to say that
shouldn't do this you know you could
like bounce yourself right back couldn't
you or you could continue to be funny
and if you go from self-control to lack
of self-control you've got problems and
if you don't have self-control when it
comes to these tempting situations you
will start to slide towards place
because at first you do things and you
know the right thing to do and you said
well you know I was overcome by my my
appetites my desires or anger got away
it seemed really it seems really nice at
the time I knew it wasn't the right
thing to do I camera rented me out about
it after a little bit I mean you know
try this out
imagine trying steal some things right
the first time you steal something
eventually comes seem normal to you and
you start thinking in terms of
challenges I still this this would be a
good thing steal and then after a while
now I didn't know you know everything's
out there for you to steal and your
desires you know hard running the show
yeah a sort of corrupt hi guys when I
was in high school it was kind of the
thing for us to steal small things but I
remember two minutes of killing these
older kids right into trouble and they
went to a shop okay I remember gas
station
candy it was gonna open up and swallow
me and I did it and we got out of there
I feel his gaze that's hard to go way
after then you know I didn't kids in
high school who specialized and things
like stealing cattle I quit on us we can
actually went to a Cadillac dealer and
just went down the row of cars because
they do is what to make keychains silly
stuff I knew other guys were stealing
big stuff who would break into things
somewhere we're specializing in radar
detectors at the time and stereos and
some other action that my friends they
had a business they called midnight
sales and services and you know the
longer you hang around with people like
that
the more you're going to start to become
a vicious the more your sense of right
and wrong is going to get skewed and the
more that it will eventually become part
of your character
we're not get it well if you had a lack
of soft control you
still better off than the business
person but if you keep doing that there
is a slide this way aerosol also does
say that was certain vices if they're
practiced too you know they go to a
really great extent they could turn into
this sort of things this brutalization
yeah that person could get stuck in
between self control and self control
but actually that in general most of us
you know think about the way the virtues
and vices and actually most people are
not actually vicious right but they do
the actions that are the actions are
vicious people but when they do that
they may actually likewise
Thanks yeah like we were doing and a lot
of us do good things but just because we
can exercise self-control I think one of
the keys for this too would be do you do
it you exercise self-control even when
some authority figure is but yeah you
could you could oscillate between the
two of these one or you could sort of
oscillate back and forth here I mean
there are people who recognize their way
of life is vicious and then they start
to make progress and that seems like
they fall back and there's people who
are here and they never seem to quite
make it to hurt you they recognize
virtues a good thing but they they
they're never able to like get
themselves to like doing the right thing
but they're able to make themselves do
good question again remember these are
sort of creations stopping points well
let's look now at some specific because
Aristotle says a lot about us he says
that we could be we could have a lack of
self-control sometimes it's translated
as weakness of will it's another way to
think of it incontinence
although I try to avoid that all sorts
of connotations in our city they are
subtle distinguishes between different
kinds and he says that if we can we can
think of it in terms the kinds of
pleasures or pains that we have a hard
time resisting that get us to not follow
principles and not make the right of
choice so what's what's getting
confidence or lack of self-control or
across per se he says it has to do with
bodily pleasures and this makes sense
what are one of the things that were
most likely to go wrong with food drink
or sexual desire which is you know by
the way we're we're living in a society
gives you enormous which exploit sour
sexual desire myriad of different ways
right
just download the full thing and some
products the way things are are set up
this is a very tough society to live
it's a very tough society to have a
virtuous disposition because there's so
much pushing there's so much actually
the way happens with those while the
person pursues these desires where they
avoid the gains that they experience
when they don't get what they want and
they don't follow up reason or
principles and so you know women sort of
classic example of that
they got thing about eating why why are
we so tempted to eat things that are bad
for us what makes food actually tastes
good the two biggest things yeah
Greece Greece is family right yeah okay
pan-pan actually is necessary before our
diet to some extent and it makes things
taste good texture he has function sugar
sweet sweetness yeah we have too much
salt at most as well and that enhances
flavor but sweetness the edge sugar of
all sorts of things it's high fructose
first row spaghetti sauce spaghetti
honey here like that we'd probably would
actually be willing to eat it how do we
do those people assault you know really
bad bad shape
so the a booth that that we like is
usually not that good for us
when Richard the food the less less food
additions but at a story something you
guys should read the Anthony for dads
kitchen because water makes things taste
good right so we have we have these
desires and lack of self control with
respect to what does that look like
now again remember lack of self control
you know what the right thing to do is
when you find yourself maybe you get up
for a midnight snack sometimes
tonight well you know been drinking you
probably want to eat something yes
alcohol plus we got a mighty way to
socialize - yeah you know the next dance
I may have maybe once in a while is okay
but finding it sweetie what about
portion size however the portion size
yeah I mean do you have any you guys
never looked at this sort of like
portion size on your time you know
amazing isn't it yeah there is once you
actually look at it that it doesn't get
disgusting but that doesn't necessarily
keep us from eating it doesn't it helps
it
well I was watching mr. I forgot what it
was called but they were showing
McDonald's and France versus McDonald's
and say yes that even like the McChicken
czar smaller like in France and like
this soda cups and whatnot are smaller
sizes I mean if you think about it you
get a large soda mcdonald's you're
currently drinking like bottle pretty
much well you know not discounting the
ice yeah but it's yeah but it still
tastes good I mean you didn't research
this you know what the right portion
size is and still find yourself
again it would be a lack of self-control
oh just speaking to healthy food tastes
good
what's the big
again lack of self-control you know a
person whose self-control who
successfully say diets and sticks to
what's healthy for them they may not
like it they may not actually be
temperate yet
temperance would be actually enjoying
the rate 14 sighs feeling good rather
than feeling deprived but it's still
following some other examples she says
there's there's incontinence in relation
to things that are instrumentally like
well this could work a couple different
ways do we spend too much yeah they've
done research because everything looks
much better than probably going because
there's nothing any frayed
virtue ethics those grocery shopping is
like it's a huge you know sure you know
for instance do you buy all premade
processed foods which are probably not
very good or do you find things that
make them from scratch making from
scratch you know it's much popular to do
what it takes of discipline doesn't I
mean you can make mac and cheese just a
good scrap mac and cheese what it takes
a work yesterday I expect probably a
good fourth of my workday making food I
baked bread yeah I made soup from
scratch let's put it up that's all it's
[ __ ] big and red pixels
we got to make sure if you're using
dried beans to actually have them sell
out the night before it waters in there
to reconstitute
but if your give it as healthier for you
yeah I suppose if we want to think of it
like a temperance with respect to food
in terms of food preparation if you
really like that then you would have a
virgin otherwise you're exercising
self-control now if I give in and I say
have throwing time to do this sort of
crab mac and cheese that would be an
example of my self-control
if I actually know this know what about
well so we'd spend things any of you
ever buy more when it comes to giving
gifts some people
so you give them a different edition
yeah there could be all sorts of things
him do do them if you ever make budgets
you probably want to get in that habit
before it started making a lot of money
because otherwise the money goes like
disappears it's amazing how quickly the
spender you know maybe the budget that's
a matter of self-control is it fun to
deprive yourself
no I only budgeted this amount for for
this I can't do this this month that's
not fun at first
after a while it can actually become fun
and that would fall under believe it or
not they would fall under that virtue of
generosity that Aristotle talks about
how you manager you're giving and you're
taking your spending yeah and it could
go the other way - there's some people
who this before we have advice of stingy
yes they they only want to take spend
anything could you have something like
that over here well let's say you have
kids and you know that you should buy
your kids new school
we don't want them to be the only kids
that don't have new clothes at school
you know what the right thing to do is
but you find yourself having this desire
to hold on with money to not do it so
you don't you don't take a shot you
don't like that could be a lack of
self-control you feel like I've watched
it but you still can't bring yourself
then you know what would be soft control
making yourself to actually spend that
money that you know so it could be on
either side it could be happy to do a
spending too much if you haven't spent
little the right things the wrong things
what else procrastination you think I
would fit into yeah until you get what
you need yeah I mean when you
procrastinate you realize at a certain
point well this is what has to get done
okay so there's some sort of principle
being involved what you find yourself
sometimes unable to follow
tell me that news exercise program
trading letters you get yourself into
that cycle where or an email or
something to somebody you're used to
correspond with them and you let it go
too long because you keep putting it off
and you don't you shouldn't and then
after a while you feel guilty about it
think about it and it takes longer and
I'm still not writing them letters and
the cycle just keeps on repeating its
own really guilty right in the letter
should be a long letter to make up its
past really you really need the time to
make it into a good letter to devote to
it to make it right that would be a lack
of self-control there so what about
making lots of plans the people
sometimes get stuck in the cycle making
tons of plans and that actually
organize this yeah organize then to
Omega all night you organized I suppose
you can spend a lot of time creating
hopefully you learn well you oh yeah
Aristotle talks about victory wanting
the desire to actually win to come out
on top
possess sometimes bringing out the worst
ones sure yeah I mean some people want
to be right all the time that can that
can lack of self-control with respect to
that being honored being whipped up two
very closely related I think he also
talks about family you know parents
children
my friends are there cases where we end
up doing the wrong thing we're not doing
the right thing because we're too
concerned with our family or friends and
we know we know that we often we find
ourselves I mean people can often turn
their domestic situation into legend I
wouldn't actually be hurt and then
what's the other big anger this is one
that's worth thinking about there's
people who have a vicious this position
with respect to anger they actually
think that they're doing the right thing
when they
hold on grudges when they get as angry
as they do about it think about people
get angry remove trivial facts where
you're like hey that that is not that
reaction that's that's out of proportion
somebody yeah that's that's a good think
about people who are upset the next day
because their team lost and they're like
you know you talk to them they're
shouting at you what's with you I mean
you know and do anything you well you
know the Bears the Jets we're lost
they were robbed that's really bad cause
like still fuming about it well you know
if they think that that's okay they're
vicious that some people will you know
tell themselves that sort of thing
there's a table on out till they
actually believe that they may find
themselves losing stop control but then
seeing that that was the anger
it's kind of funny to think about sports
teams people shout the TV things that's
how what I'm like professor you have a
black guy he decided to become a voice
man through his remote at the floor I'll
bounce right back at him in the eye
sometimes people to analyze things
if we think about this this cycle you
know there's losing control because a
banker
there's raining in your anger even
though you don't feel like it
and then there's no the virtue of the
state one sec where the person gets
angry at the right time to the right of
mouth to the degree of the fishes at the
right people
which is probably going to be not
getting very angry just like there's
videos on YouTube of people like hidden
cameras and people when they find out
that like their girlfriend and mom was
like cancel the world of warcraft
and it is just so great it's like that
the walk made me feel great interest
yeah it's looking alternative way yeah
we're doing there's probably a whole
genre video yeah you know it's
interesting as I am responses let's
think of a few other examples sexual
pleasure you know that's one that
blogging gets us do people do things
that they recognize at the time right
the right thing to do but they feel it's
all sort of overcome by caching caching
lost desire traction the main end up
doing the wrong thing and it's not the
same thing as somebody who actually
thinks that what they're doing is okay
somebody that says yeah this is not the
right thing but I found myself I'm even
surprised us whatever what are some of
the example is it sexual
what about cheating breaking up some
sort of relationship yeah
risky behavior I mean you know think of
all the different things that could go
wrong you don't know somebody very well
and you're sleeping
first off they could be nuts yeah you
might wake up next to them you know who
knows whatever they're in your credit
cards or they don't look anything like
you thought they look good night well
that's yeah yeah I mean if you're going
to actually say sleep around
indiscriminately
what would the prudence actually tell
you you probably should you know we're
some sort of protection sort of things
but people get overcome by desire no
very easy to do I mean just think back
to the beginnings of which which is not
that long ago for you guys even for me
think back to what was like these
hormones just coursing through your
system find yourself unable to tear your
eyes
it's hard to resist that isn't it's hard
to resist the lure of pleasure
what's there's one other thing I want to
to hit up as well Aristotle talks about
some of the different ways in which our
reasoning can get screwed up and when it
comes to a lack of self-control one of
these he calls impetuosity or you could
think about it was just jumping into
things in this case the person whatever
it is that's attracting them or
compressing on them it gets there first
you might say and they don't actually
start thinking about it they just
started acting angered or often works
like that doesn't but so can talk in
sexual desire so can the wish to to beat
everybody else it's also a competitive
situation that's he thinks in certain
respects less the problem the winning
person actually has thought about and
they say this is the wrong thing to do
but I'm which may be more likely than
eating although eating could work both
ways you're sitting at the restaurant
everybody's having a good time you know
the tension of things somebody put
something in front of you you don't
realize that it's too big too rich
things in that there's desserts going to
be following to pick whatever you want
that could be impossible in many cases
it's a lack of follow-through
there is another thing to the inventions
that I want to bring up is every time
that we exercise self-control we say I'm
gonna do what I choose to do is that
always good to be but if I want
somebody's stubborn you talk to them he
says that that's not really soft control
the stubborn person is able to resist
things that are attempting them but they
also resist a lot of things that they
probably shouldn't resist so he says so
there's some persons who stand by their
opinions and we call hops to them
meaning they're hard to convince and not
easily persuaded to change their
convictions they bear some resemblance
to the self-restraint person but they're
really different in many respects the
self-restraint person stands firm
against one
what did what are they actresses fashion
designer pleasures things that attract
us things that we've just to do what
does the obstinate person other people
telling them this is the right thing to
do they're not going to do it because
it's not the right thing they didn't
choose well then what they're doing is
they're standing up against reason to
the self control person once act the
self control person is actually
following reason against their desire
the obstinate person is following
something else against reason so what do
you what do you think there
actually follow science
what kind of desires to be right yeah
that same wish for for victory like you
says there they're often led by pleasure
and you distinguishes between
opinionated is stupid end of the world
oceans the motives of opinionated our
pleasure and pain the air so he's ready
you can find any of religious tradition
have had some people who are opinionated
they've got their I learned this back in
Bible School and I'm never gonna blood
sure that's sort of the sort of benefit
I can speak most about like you know the
Christian theological tradition I can
say this yeah that's where the attitude
goes against the mainstream of Christian
law with you know if you look at say the
Sermon on the Mount right
central Christian ethics yeah this Jesus
guy telling the crowd bless these people
you know do these same things like if
you're angry with your brother you have
to make up with him he's not saying
anything like pick what you want to
leave and just stick to that don't
listen to anybody you're not going to
find that info right and you're not
going to find that in one of the other
scriptural passages you're not going to
find that in the broad stream of
Christian thought you're not going to
find st. Thomas of coins or st. Anne's
house or even the people who are very
close to the time
really Christian community they'll say
things like well if this is any good we
ought to be able to provide some
justification for it without me to
explain ourselves and so the mainstream
mainstream of the intellectual position
Krishna has always resisted that's right
you can still find a lot of people who
are going to say no I learned this
that's all there is to it and a lot of
times those are hard people to to teach
even in a Bible class right now I think
you could say the same thing for any
other group of distribution as well and
it's interesting that you bring that up
too because these categories get used
within Christian ethics and Jewish to
make sense of things the notion of Vice
yes being something that firstly has a
rooted in their soul that disposition
and it's not just people here
which is also people like say say August
and they they thought that you had to
procedure this exercise your will so the
stubborn person would be in a way sort
of shirt short-circuiting their
spiritual work again we're getting
pretty far down here at some of us but
it's a good question
maybe it was something that makes us bit
more relevant that's what will happen
so we've got a pretty odd with with that
condition something is happened to the
nurse and that's that's different than
just plain old price where we can hold
the person more or less response
Aristotle says that brutality is in some
ways not as bad as bias it's not as
reprehensible applies but in other ways
it's more horror why would that be well
there's become damaged in the brutalized
person when the ruler's person who
literally has become more animalistic
the word that we translate his brutality
there means
some of them who's like an animal so
they could think of it like this you
have the this human soul and you have
this rational part and that's part of
what separates you from the other
animals dogs are nice right a lot of
boxes pets but dogs are just animals
they have their own nature they are not
rational beings they do communicate with
each other they don't communicate like
this like I said before a dog doesn't he
asked itself the question in my head why
I've got good habits by exercising soft
control any dog doesn't take control
it's off that way do I doesn't worry
about fairness or impose you know
fairness on other people or itself does
well what can land us
like Aristotle talks about number
different cases
it says the vicious person the highest
part of their being the rational part of
their being which want to pervade all of
your that you know all the dimensions of
your being it's either not there at all
or it got damaged in some way or it's
out of commission you might say or it
didn't develop as it as it should it
only probably developed the vicious
person was managed to corrupt something
important themselves they managed to
corrupt that rational part so it gives
them the wrong answers
the brutal person didn't even get that
far
the vicious person can't see what the
right and genuinely good thing is
because of their advice and if they get
rid of that lice they would get better
and that requires me I'm changing the
character though
the brutal person some of them you may
not be able to do anything with they may
be so so damaged that they can never
actually see the good as the good they
can never see what they're doing is
actually yeah and so we said that the
vicious person bears responsibility for
their part no they can't snap their
fingers who could it be ambitious right
away but they are responsible we talked
about this back three
through their actions but the person
who's for health there's something wrong
there that's a different work they don't
really have a choice they're not acting
basis haven't formed their character
through choices
it could be that something else is
formative for them so they don't bear
responsibility what would be some
instances in this well think about will
be some cases think back to the book 3
we talked about this what would be some
cases review yourself personally would
not hold another person responsible for
their they're clearly bad behavior not
just one but one would you know
okay so if there's something actually
wrong with their their mind maybe
there's an organic problem right there
there there are some things that we
concludes to some degree with with
pharmaceuticals you know there are some
people who can get stabilized a bit to
get some of the things we give them a
creative high-powered price but somebody
who's manic or bipolar it might give
them lithium that's pretty high-powered
treatment
there's anti-psychotic drugs people who
have a psychosis they're really the
attachment reality they'd like you know
I'm going to attack people because they
think they're demons some people hear
voices you can give them drugs that
might alter their brain chemistry this
can be more or less successful there
could be some people who are damaged
because it's some sort of birth defect
part of their brain doesn't it doesn't
develop attention getting them drugs is
programmed in that case the psycho
supplies that's missing but yeah we want
them to hold people responsible or the
other case
yeah kids can do some pretty to right
effects although sometimes we do try
them as adults that would be holding
them responsible we do it no penal
institutions for them
I had a music teachers teacher placement
whales over boys and this is where they
put all the murderers and rapists and
yeah the kids were doing really bad
things who were under 18 and they tried
to stand there actually a music teacher
luckily he actually had a fake leg it
was kind of kind of sporty get a fake
leg for because he didn't be been in a
car accident and so we had an entire
thing like music lessons kid who tried
to trying to stand up stand into this
fake leg and of course he didn't flinch
cried out or anything like that the kid
the guards came and so that nobody
invested them ever again because they
thought he was so tough but you could
like take the stand
you know the effective way but you know
isn't that kid stabbed him you know
there were other cases to school for
boys where
other teacher got raped did you have
murdered in the moments all these are
these are kids that there's something
wrong do we punish that the same as
adults
not usually
people who are suffering addiction now I
know in our society there was a lot of
this addiction of that addiction
let's do anything about like hard drugs
somebody who's addicted to crystal meth
or cocaine do we hold them responsible
in the same way as you know junkies
feels there's other people who love
stealing that's a vicious disposition
would you hold the junkie responsible in
the same way
just
yeah you can you can say that they have
made themselves that way and so they
made it passed down through the scale
Aristotle actually says you know other
things to certain vices like
cowardice or if they tend to really deep
excess intention was this kind of
morbidity or sickness and after a
certain point it seems like Aristotle
says there's something that shifts when
the person is no longer responsible for
the behavior and again he says this is
this is more horrific than us because
the person seems to be less of a person
well we talked about them not being the
same person addiction you know
there's a there's a question about how a
responsible person is there is a gene
that predisposes people towards
excessive alcohol
yeah and you know there's some of the
issues that it seems a little bit harder
to make the case like sex addiction
are they really totally out of control
or maybe are they dishes you know I
think that's probably vicious unless
almost maybe there's something going the
haywire in the brain but somebody who's
actually become addicted to to here at
certain point they gasp and then there
are lost right there's no way to get out
of there
until they're maybe over here what about
people who suffer horrific abuse there's
so much she talks about that you know it
might surprise you to find that he talks
about acquired Kamath's he talks about
resistant terms of little things that
make the family who yard he says there
could be acquired habits which are
developed through living and culture
with very bad customs so you know if you
grow up in a society that thinks that
killing people is a-ok you're probably
gonna be pretty screwed up aren't you
you're going to have you may be so
screwed up that you actually fit into
this maybe
there's a lot of variety there's their
sexual use they lacked children who
suffered horrific neglect it may be
quite difficult to even place them on
the rest of the small spectrum they're
unable to relate to other people some
some children have what's called the
attachment disorder and everything it's
a bond with the parents it turns out
that's actually important for normal
moral development and what you can get
out of that is somebody who first as a
child an adult can't relate to other
people and may in fact be quite
dangerous because Aristotle would call
that a a brutal estate he actually talks
about childhood sexual abuse you know
children who are are sexually abused
what happens how does that transform
their horrible world think about what
goes on is it's usually going to be
somebody who's you know not just random
stranger it's somebody who's involved in
their life but they can't get away from
and somebody who want to be treating
them in a loving way right so what do
they come to come to see they come to
see that this is the best things can be
and I am to be an object for this person
and that means other people later on you
know I'm sure are just objects for me
one reason why abused children are at
much greater risk for being abusive
themselves directly because excused the
entire moral universe depending on how
bad the abuse is let me let me bring up
two examples that you could think of
that one's pretty recent I may have
mentioned this in class before it's
actually going to try to cap it in my
home state of Wisconsin but he has been
following the story about this girl who
was essentially starved to death
well her step mother and father and her
son were eating up above overweight
massively overweight and cooking food
and all that they made her live in the
basement it was just a sink anything
like that
they did a lot of horrific things for
sexual abuse as well when they would let
her out of the basement
it was to go out in the yard and the
cinder blocks around
just a treasure maker let's say you know
[ __ ]
now she's someone that our hands does
she ever going to be that a completely
cold person that that really depends and
aerosol if she were to end up doing bad
things as a result aerosol probably the
[ __ ] Coulter is responsible as so many
others any other thing my boss when you
build wishes behaviors monster I'll give
you another sexual ease when I first
moved to Indiana there's a famous case
of Indianapolis where a couple had been
pimping out their children for years and
a section their kids were from like five
through ten years old and they would
make the children have sex with other
people
and also perform sex shows with each
other and if the kids didn't do that
they would they would whip them and so
these kids were really brutalized now
that's pretty horrific abuse that you
know that's going pretty far so they
they took the kids already thank God
yeah they went to prison
like again which is good
the kids were all put in a foster home
and you're trying to keep kids together
you know they've been in traumatic
situations as they help to support each
other they had to be transferred from
the foster home because they had to be
split up because the only way that these
kids do how they relate to each other
was by having sex with each other
so that's how they would interact with
each other you know that goes far beyond
cancer vicious
you know orientations towards sexuality
and how they want to relate to other
people there's something that we removed
from those kids lives you know we often
talk about abuses destroy innocence
that's a clear case where so a lot of
these pieces of brutalization are going
to be like Aerith all talks about a few
other the interesting examples
to resist you know certain more of it
states that they had not then certain
diseases can do this to people as well
certain diseases can affect your
neurology can't they people like to put
those in those doctor shows like house
person actually you know starts behaving
in a radical way because they have got
some sort of a fever that's that's
affecting their hair so I would say
they're not responsible for their
actions again you know distress his plan
he says it's not as bad at one sense but
if it's worse in another sense because
what's distinctively human about them
has been damaged to such a degree vice
damages what's distinctively human us
our moral compass we were honest their
sense of right and wrong
if damages that are corrupted but it
doesn't destroy it
with brutality it's effectively
destroyed